[Music]
if you thought that the fashion at the
2018 MTV Video Music Awards red carpet
was head-turning just wait until you see
what came after Kylie Jenner headed into
a post-show party rocking head to toe
leather swapping out her bright white
blazer dress for a black bustier
high-waisted pants and ankle booties
ariana grande went from this to this
[Applause]
then ended the night in a more comfy
cozy look dressing it down in a hoodie
and her signature over-the-knee boots
Jennifer Lopez Slade on the carpet and
during her performance but it was this
skin tight Versace number after the show
that had her looking like a total boss
Tiffany Haddish was on trend changing
out this gown to rock a sheer sparkly
jumpsuit cardi B opted for a slick black
option trading her colorful dress for
this ruffled little black dress the
Empress
then there's Rita Ora who looked
flawless before the show and some
Lorraine Schwartz black diamond but it
was this feathered frock after the show
that had us saying bow down so so so
scandalous
[Applause]
you